oh my god
okay um i have to close and relaunch
this game
just because i have to show you
something that happened at the loading
screen
this is carrion by the way just hold on
i'll i'll be right back
you'll see what i mean in just a second
oh it didn't even oh didn't even show it
okay so
this is uh supposedly a reverse horror
game
where instead of being the victim you're
the horrible meat monstrosity with
unlimited teeth
and an abyss for eyes and cover art that
looks like a vagina
not gonna lie on the switch this game
came out and they had to change the
cover art because it looked like this
which licks in you might as well just
blur that you have to look it up for
yourself
anyway it's an interesting concept
a little gross oh hey
eeny meeny miny kaboom oh
oh you poor poor people eeny meeny miny
kaboom
anybody noticing this anybody noticing
what's happening here come on
come on
where do i go what do i do what do i do
where do i go god i'm so scared
all right hold this oh you're right
about that
oh
oh that's creep i oh my god
oh wow i've never been on this side of
the whole equation before
i'm coming for you you should be scared
[Music]
maybe if they weren't day trading up
there instead of looking at their damn
unit
oh this is cool yeah right there
it's fine don't worry about it hey
i'm over here i'm nowhere to be found
all right i'm moving on sorry uh oh
[Music]
man i could have voice acted for this
game
man i sure do goose a lot of blood oh i
love the music
i said i love the music and the music
kicked up a notch i think it news
okay interesting so there's something
about left shift
oh i see i see i see i i think this
computer here
no how about up here okay what do i do
oh i see there's a tube
hello i love you
hello oh my god
yeah maybe maybe definitely sound the
alarms hello
hi i'm going down here
hello hold to grab objects
oh wow i really grabbed that
i am exceptionally strong
oh my god all right cool i love the
style
this is super fun this is super cool
grab humans with right pull them towards
you to consume them
oh no are they on the toilet oh i'm so
sorry
not
you didn't notice this
well this is your mistake
i feel a sense of power growing inside
of me
unyielding unstoppable
oh that just opened i was gonna rip that
off
[Laughter]
i feel unstoppable the squirming
wriggling mass of flesh and power
oh this is awesome i i'm actually
thoroughly enjoying myself
you better run blind rubber rubber
slam the door of scares hey
it's me greg come on back
it's greg
[Laughter]
missed this piece and this piece
okay hang on wait wait wait wait wait
hold on it's fine it's fine it's fine
hey it's fine
it's me steve and greg it's me greg
come back
how is this working oh my god i'm
enormous
i am probably too big all right is there
anyone else out there
oh it's bae greg steve
and stacy coast is clear
i think they've grown wise to my tactics
it's your birthday
we got cake you're gonna love it
oh cake what kind of cake what kind of
cake
it's chocolate i hate chocolate oh
oh man it's ice cream ice cream cake get
in here quick it's gonna melt oh it's
gonna melt
we gotta get there quick all right fine
they're too smart for this
they're the clever ones that's why
they're still alive oh
boy that was spooky why didn't you come
to the party the ice cream cake melted
yeah i'm a little big
i suppose you guys could have gone
through that door that probably seems
like it might have worked out a little
better
this door had betrayed me this game is
dope
oh yeah i can turn off electronics with
this
bluff
here squeeze in i'm a squeeze screws
that switch oh if only they had gone for
the switch
maybe they had just survived
but no unfortunately i'm such a tube of
meat
i'm just a meatball
but i'm kind of cute little cute oh
freedom oh my god freedom it's
tantalizing
they're doing this on purpose in this
game they're tantalizing me
bring it up to glorious freedom
shiny light me like spread biomass and
save
oh wow
what
all right squeeze it's alive
i got an achievement ah
something's trying to get in it's me hi
how you doing
seal's breached biomass samples lost wow
that's unfortunate
wait 50 is there another one of me is
there a competitor
do i have to kill again do i have to
kill freisley
how many times oh is this freedom no
wait a minute let me see what's in here
uh hi authorized personnel only looks
like i can't get through here
there's something almost like a lot of
spaghetti being slapped
quickly on the other side of this door
very strange whatever
freedom
freedom oh well that's not freedom
freedom freedom freedom
this is so cool this is so cool this is
so cool
i love this i really do i love the
weight of it
wango ra i'm coming for you
maybe i can grab something and i can
wang doodle it on that how about this
tiny box
yes tiny box i love you
tiny bucks
peter oh who crumbled the dust how about
this
i shall break you oh there's some tough
wood
tougher than that metal sorry just had
to come back a second
oh interesting what's up here freedom
frida oh what is this carbo
freedom you move so surprisingly quick
it's it's fascinating because it's so
fast
it's fascinating
can i squeeze through here uh i can you
just
barely you're oh god i'm slapping my
meat tentacles as hard as i can
[Music]
it's so close oh god
if only i fine whatever
hello hello hello oh squeeze it squeeze
in what am i oh
that i thought you were that i thought
oh that's gonna be tough to scrub out
oh what is oh where am i
a military junkyard huh okay yeah sure
military junkyard
sure clunk
shouldn't have left all this military
stuff in a junkyard
oh who dare you think that piddly little
gun is gonna get me
hey i'll be back for you ignore all the
blood flowing down from the ceiling
ow hello
maybe there was someone over here oh
uh uh listen there's a pizza party
why don't you just open this door
peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo close it oh god i'm coming
for you
all right that didn't go to plan but
that's okay he only had a
freaking bullet shooter not gonna hurt
me
poink spread by a mess
whoa oh
what the hell i love it i love
it oh you're echoing back
that this game is dope
hey uh don't open the door i'm not ready
the party's not ready hello
no one's here what was
that hello oh something's over there
something's up hello ah goodbye hello
goodbye
hello goodbye
hmm hello
miss me sorry
you gonna reload how many bullets does
that gonna have
so you like jazz
i guess she doesn't like jazz
oh there's a gate i'm sorry a little
awkward
hello hi oh hi
excuse me sorry don't mind me
uh oh this is weird
oh god they drown oh
all right fine
kind of vicious but at the same time
it's the miracle of life
ah there i go i fell hi how you doing
um yeah ignore that sound
it was nothing
hi
that's a freaking wilhelm scream
all right oh i can fit in here hello
and boosh now that wasn't nearly as
explosive as the other one was
but just as creepy crawly
all right good hey this is going great i
just
i'm having a ball i'm having a
hello brother brother
brother brother wake up
oh brother squeezing
brother whoa
a arachnopticis shoot a cobweb
to trap your victims or interact with
objects okay
i love it i love that
that's dope i love that
if only i could reach it
zip
i've apparently got her skittle nuddled
in by the little zipped up
guard
hi
it's vicious it's vicious hi
something's above you something's above
you that wants to say hi
skoosh all right hello
i meant to be gentle with that gentle
gentle hello wait wait a minute what's
over here
hi you've been webbed
[Music]
what happened
oh my god can they swim
nope they cannot swim oh
that was mean i mean this i've got to
eat them anyway so
i guess it's all horrible
oh well i need one more of those before
i can
go into the whatever butthole that is oh
that unfortunate for them
really unfortunate you hate to see it
you really hate to see that
that right there you
oh i'm a pancake hello
how you doing you know how to use doors
you guys all right
you just gotta grab them open them there
you go have fun
did she fall oh she fell oh no oh she's
fine
okay she's fine
i don't know why i'm going like oh no
she fell
yummy hi
bye squeeze
all right that's some good stuff hello
where am i now i can't get in here this
is not where i should be
up here up here up here over here
speedrun baby this would be a fun game
to speedrun i bet
i'm not gonna do it no way in hell but
it'd be fun
i'm sure at some point machines can
expire too yeah of course i'm sure that
at some point they're gonna
pull out the big guns on me oh
they're gonna pull out the big guns on
me and i'm just gonna i'll be ready
sam the seals breached 50 containment
using locked
status breached is that good or bad did
i do good did i get everything
i don't know
i don't know what i just what did i just
squeeze into
holy crap
oh was that a good idea or a bad idea
what did i just do
pardon me pardon
pardon me
um paul
all right okay well being a human is
kind of fun i guess
i don't know how i tapped into this
person's memories but
here i am i guess a lot of the powers of
this horrible monstrosity would be weird
a disorganized mass of bones and dry
tissue well you don't need to be rude
about it
oh plan c4 oh run apparently no
stop stop run away this is where you run
this is this is where you run oh my god
what are you doing
okay
i sincerely thought that it was just ai
being very dumb
uh yeah buddy yeah baby
let me get in here okay
cool i don't know what that was all
about
but at least i opened up that so i'm
guessing the moral of the story is it's
a bunch of scientists that were
exploring and found something that they
shouldn't have and tried to bring it
back to life to study it
and that was where they made their
mistake
pal friendo
hey
ah those are heavy i'm too wimpy for
that
thank you thank you very much
bluff
mmm tasty
where am i oh uranium mines
how devious how dastardly
i love it
specifically uranium hello goodbye sorry
boink hi sorry i need to
eat thank you munch
munch munch and crunch
a bunch of munchie cruncher i guess
there's a way that people could be
sneaky about this but
i don't need to and i just charge in
tentacles blazing
up no down down i say
hello oh love the love the environment
hello ignore that it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine you're fine
ow what the hell hey rude
shoot web on you web out
ow oh my biomass
thank you thank you thank you thank you
man those bullets are really biomass
eaters
i guess i can't just go charging in
tentacles blazing
i guess i just did that hey pal how you
doing
hey listen listen listen
listen you listening good
i like you i'm gonna leave you alone
don't worry about it don't worry about
it hey it's all good
i like you
i wonder if you could get through this
game without killing anybody
i'm not gonna do it not not really my
play style but you know it's i wonder if
it'd be possible i
mean no one asked me to kill anybody i
just did it anyway
who knew oh solji
you don't know where i am soldier i'm a
shadow in the night
full of lover where did i go what
happened to me
so strange
ow what the hell you suck
ow ow ow okay you know
ow you are rude
you're very rude oh this this suit's
tough to get through apparently
doesn't seem to be working awfully tough
to digest
look out a distraction don't never
oh god
got him well i am just a tiny blob again
hopefully something tasty and less oh my
goodness
they should have defended this a bit
harder bam
hello brother mind if i fit in
damage vent covers and water walls slash
enemies
i like it ziphoria like diarrhea
but ziff i think i can appreciate that
this is what some might call the good
stuff
oh my goodness oh wow i'm
big i'm real big hey
yeah i'm real big
oh i'm a lump oh i'm a big lump
oh my god i'm horrible i'm a horror show
but i love it here wham
you are blam
don't worry i'll be back for you
squeeze squeeze squeeze
squeeze don't run don't walk backwards
what over there
oh oh hi i never would have noticed that
i don't think i opened the other shaft
when i opened did i open the other one
no god i meant to do this
hello
hello bam
bam i am big and strong
i can't get through here hey
hey bud how you doing it's been a while
i know i'm looking a little different
hey come on it's your friend
okay you know you're being a little rude
you need to stop screaming right now
[Music]
it's just so great and i have so many
new ears now
you keep screaming like that and i might
get
upset i might do something i regret
i might do something that you wouldn't
like
i might do something a little drastic so
why don't you just cut the screaming
okay good
okay good thank you that's fine
i can hardly blame him i am a sight to
behold i know i know
oh hey yeah i don't think i opened
did i open the other one i don't know
oh hey there we go squeeze
can hardly squeeze you know what i mean
getting real girthy
getting real thick status secure uh
oh yeah i don't know about that
hmm interesting
hi bye
hi oh i think i only have the other
power when i'm bigger ah that makes
sense
anybody need to be girthy to use my full
blasting of power
i see okay i think i need to start being
a little more sneaky about this
hello i'm sneaky
what was that noise weird
you saw nothing you saw nothing
what was that weird
mancha crunch
oh well i can knock them over with stuff
i throw
man they really they're really tough to
chew
should be looking at me not the oh
hello bye hey
hey don't worry if you don't attack me
i don't want to attack you that's the
deal
now you guys stay in here where it's
safe
hey don't worry about it you guys are
gonna be fine
i really am thoroughly enjoying this
game
this is super fun samples wait
where is this oh
that's right that's right that's right
military junkyard except that i missed
something did i miss something in here
i mean i guess now that i have the power
maybe there was like a wooden barricade
that i could break through and that's
why it's sending me back
is there a map oh hello
i'm here now hiya hello
hi how are you
good to see you hi
hello i'm here it's your friend
oh yeah how's everyone doing squeezing
in
don't mind me like nothing happened hi
hello how you doing up here making a
video gaming here you
slacking off you goofing huh you wasting
comedy time
all right cool all right stay safe
everybody there's some
weird stuff happening today weird stuff
maybe i gotta
squeeze in here
excuse me just gonna grab this computer
just gonna see if any any no no oh sorry
slip of the tentacle didn't mean that
sorry
well i uh can't seem to oh i it's so
simple and obvious oh i can't do it if i
don't have
oh i need to lose some biomass
i literally can't do it until i lose
some biomass oh deposit biomass oh
oh gross all right but fair fair fair
shot it out like an egg scheduled
schedule at ease catalytics catalytic
grab and consume the cocoon to retrieve
biomass absolutely
i love that eat myself hello
hi how did we do that i'll see you
around
hello do you letty
[Applause]
oh my
oh cool it's got a little
dude scuttle it let's kill it
nah come on come on
guys come on
damn it meant to hit him oh god the
mistake mistake mistake was made
wow that's fine it's fine it's all good
it's all good here yeah i'll deposit
some i'll deposit some i don't need all
that
what i got him mine crunch
bro
can't really eat them they're tough to
eat they don't digest properly
delicious squeeze hi
oh what do you have here hi
hiding secrets sorry didn't know that
would blow up like that
oh locate edible corpses
well i can't find them where are those
edible corpses i have no idea
who wouldn't know jarg
hi it's me hello
[Applause]
where'd this go
seals breached oh yeah yeah yeah cob
boom
i love it
fun frontier marshlands okay
apparently i'm in some kind of a marsh
or something i don't know
what are these what are these big what
are those
they sure did design a lot of things in
this facility to keep me out
real smartly like am i gonna need to
deposit my biomass
oh oh well something's blocking my way
hello
interesting i see okay
i'm here now where is here hello
oh that doesn't look good that doesn't
look it that doesn't look good that's
not good
oh no no no no no no no no no you don't
do that to me oh you don't do that to me
oh no no no
go down go get wrecked get wrecked get
wrecked
i did it i don't know exactly what i did
keep calm and carry on yeah i don't know
about that
oh hi
here i go apparently i don't know what
the hell this is supposed to be
i don't know what the hell this is
supposed to like technologically serve
why it needs such a big machine why it
seems specifically designed for me
anyway let's carry on we got a job to do
you know it kind of reminds me of out of
this world in terms of graphics and like
interactivity and the way things move
the old
like nintendo game super nintendo out of
this world if anyone else is getting
those vibes let me know because i'm
feeling it big and strong
oh fun cause of death massive head
trauma
massive absolutely massive did i analyze
that
that looks interesting that's
fascinating
that is definitely something to observe
i got nothing to say about it though
um mum's the word when it comes to
whatever that is
if i said anything i would be so
disappointed in myself
hurry up other people i'm used to the
the speed of the
of the conglomeration of whatever the
other was the name of this game cocoon
creature cthulhu
klondike bar carrion that's it
move so quick this humi moves so slow
examine hmm
the lever is missing a rod
i'm fine everybody jump down apparently
it's okay
hmm yeah this seems safe uh
yeah okay yeah sure yeah let's just go
ow oh my goodness anything to say about
this smartypants
nope not a word not a single word
but i got the lever rod so that's nice
and then there's this thing
okay good oh that's not good calcified
remains of a cyclopian entity of
unknown origin yeah the the way the
water's kind of blurbing up
definitely not on the good side of
things on the good bad spectrum that's
definitely a bad
most certainly a bad pull yeah pull
pull hard oh so strong so big and so
strong
hey you waited for me instead of jumping
down that was um
really feels like you abandoned me oh
awesome awesome
up i go oh we'll change sure don't worry
guys i'll do
literally all the work you guys just
stand around wait for my genius brain
okay and run off ahead of me great good
thank you
oh goodness didn't think we'd actually
make it to something
substantial i'll just go in the water
yeah this is fine
this is definitely not contaminating
anything collect those samples
the perfect organism i wonder how it all
connects
i wonder what it all means it's also
confusing
oh yeah i'm back to this thing
yes
hello botanical gardens you say
sounds like there's a lot of biomass
hey wait a minute i need to deposit some
where's some water
here we go okay
thank you hi if
you didn't see a thing hello
and they're they and they i didn't do
that
i did not do that and also i'm not gonna
let them go to waste
just because they made that mistake does
not mean that i need to go hungry
hi it's me hello
what's in here more silly people hi
oh no look out it's a cage
okay well that yeah that's no good
i'm big now that's me
look out oh my god i'm so sorry
oh god can't let it go to waste oh god
god dude my dude don't come over here
all right i'm in the botanical gardens
hi i don't know where i was before
apparently not the botanical gardens
hello
hi how you doing ah
hi
so i want to die munch
where did that open oh good great thank
you
thank you for that what's in here
hello goodbye
whoa whoa interesting
like i would carry the corpse along with
me just in case
all right cool good uh chunk a lot
chunka
can i squeeze in here can i zap it no
all right wee oh
well that's still a problem well that's
still a problem
that's still a problem hey lady can you
flip the switch up there would you mind
giving it off
a a flip all right fine i'll go this way
that i unlocked
you heard nothing
well that does the job just hit him with
something
thank you
hello hi
excuse me i'm gonna need this
you didn't see a thing very strange
damn it
all right easy let me either let me
through let me through let me through
i gotta go to the bathroom hello
can you flip the switch no okay thank
you oh here we go
kaboom
lady uh you're only gonna get two more
chances to flip that switch for me
or else it's gonna get real meaty in
there like a meat lover's pizza
whoa hey don't play with fire
oh zoey
i take your here's your friend help him
he's in trouble he's in a lot of pain
yipes you kind of stink buddy
hello hey did you know your buddy kind
of stinks all right cool see you
hello oh that wasn't the thing that i
thought it was going to do
what is that all about all right what's
in here
nothing scootally doodly doodly doodly
doo
oh no no no no no no ow ow
oh no oh no
ow bonk throw it down there
take that i don't know what that's all
about is there another one
there's one more it's down there i'm
gonna hit you with my body
oh god can i
there we go
man those kind of suck also i kind of
suck but whatever
oh it's beautiful hello you're not so ow
we god damn it
oh ow ow
ow
munch no meat on those things ah god
dang it
dang it i ran out of meat
meat meet mama
thank you meat mama wham
hello fun oh
all right lady once again last chance um
it's gonna be
so incredibly meaty in there like you
have no idea how much meat is gonna go
in and around that area it's gonna be
like meat central
so if you just flip the switch you'd
make my life a lot easier
hi buddy bye buddy
oh god oh god no no no now
this guy whining we all got problems
italy a lot of little lady lotta little
hey what's going on over here oh i see
what's going on over here
i'm a little too meaty is what you're
saying got a little too much meat on my
bones
i should have taken a few more lumps
yeah i get you i get your habits to the
best of us
excuse me i need my lumps uh never mind
i can't get my lumps
hello where's my lumps
oh ah well at least i got this
thank you what is this
photokinesis bend light and cream
invisibility cloak requires energy to
use
oh i don't have any energy i can steal
your energy apparently
sure oh i know how this works
oh i got it oh i got it
watch this oh yeah
oh yeah that's the good stuff oh that is
the best stuff
that is in fact the good stuff okay so
if i just
pull that the other way go up here grab
my meat
go back oh but then how am i going to be
able to oh
i didn't think that through it's fine
oh gosh darn it oh do i have to go all
the oh my god
where's the switch oh my god it's over
here
oh my god
it's quite a reset switch very
inconvenient for even humans to deal
with okay careful careful careful
i'm i i was holding it down oh i can't
do it in this form
oh i'm too beefy i'm
going i'm going and stealth mode i'm
like a shadow in the night
fools
well that's awfully convenient wish i'd
done that sooner
i warned you there's kind of a gaping
butthole situation going on there
hi don't mind me
you thought you saw a big thing turns
out
what you actually saw was really
absolutely nothing
stupid fool
that's a lot of flames oh my god
yikes oh my goodness gravy
stupid fool wow
that's very hot i'm going to burn you
i'm going to roll no
kill it kill it kill him kill him
[Music]
you silly fool you left me alive that
was your first mistake
you're second coming into work today i'm
so small should activate your shield
buddy boo
all right good thing i got this biomass
over here
easy almost too easy
i guess i didn't need to get that back
but whatever it feels good
hello i'm here now
excellent all right now i sh can i poop
out something
i need to poop out i need to poop i need
to poop
can i poop here can i poop here can i
poop here i gotta poop
or can i i don't know can i poop over
here ah not there
i just need a spot to poop please poop
where can i poop poop there anywhere
literally anywhere
oh that's not a poopable this isn't poop
how do i i can't i just need so badly to
poop
where can i poop i can poop up here and
poop oh my god i've left so much poop
there i'm just a single cell organism
i am so vulnerable maybe i'm so cute
look at me look how cute i am look at
how cute i am
okay and then oh shoo oh
made it see lady if you just
if you'd just been nice everything would
have been fine
if you just thrown that switch all would
have been good
it all would have been good but you just
had to not do something
fine whatever kaboom kabang
pabowski love it all right
and with that i think i'm going to end
this one here this is a very fun game
but i don't plan to do a full
playthrough of it
like as fun as it definitely is oh
there's my biomes as fun as it
definitely is
it was it's a cool mechanic it's a
really fun game to play
but uh i think one off is enough for me
so thank you everybody so much for
watching uh this game is on steam if you
want to check it out go for it i think
it's super fun and it's an interesting
idea
so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]